O que pode ser feito para vesícula com
lama e cistos de pâncreas? Bem, vamos
falar aqui um pouquinho sobre a
abordagem do ponto de vista da medicina
funcional, da medicina mais convencional
e também da visão ortomolecular, tá? O
que que é a lã biliar? É uma mistura de
colesterol, sais de cálcio que se
acumulam quando a vesícula não consegue
esvaziar totalmente ou de forma
adequada. Então, tratamento convencional
incluiria mudança de dieta, sendo que
pessoas com lama na vesícula podem
sentir dificuldade para digerir
alimentos pesados ou alimentos
demasiadamente gordurosos. Então, o
ácido urso deoxicólico
ou urso desoxicólico, né, o údica, ele
pode ser utilizado para fidificar a bi e
dissolver pequenos cálculos. Dentro da
medicina funcional, o que que representa
a lama biliar? Ela representa disfunções
metabólicas que estão por trás, estão
subjacentes, que devem ser corrigidas
através aí de mudanças de estilo de
vida. Vamos falar um pouquinho sobre o
suporte nutricional. Então você que tem
lama biliar, você pode utilizar colina e
ousitol, que são importantes paraa
síntese de fosfatid colina, que mantém a
solubilidade do colesterol na bile,
evitando a lama. Você pode usar taurina,
que vai ajudar na conjugação de biliares
e melhorar a fluidez da bile. Você pode
usar lecitina de girassol, que também é
rica em fófatidolina e vai auxiliar na
emulsificação de gorduras. E aí é
interessante fazer também modulação
antioxidante. Você pode usar o gluta
pode usar o NAC, que vão dar proteção a
célula do fígado e melhorar a fase dois
de detox. A vitamina E com selênio.
Lembrando aqui que eu tô falando das
oito formas de vitamina E que vão
provocar uma redução do estresse
oxidativo e vai contribuir para
alterações positivas na parte biliar. a
curcumina pelas propriedades
antipinatórias e colagogas, né, que é de
você ajudar na excreção de bile. Suporte
digestivo é muito importante com enzimas
digestivas pancreáticas que vão
compensar a redução da função biliar. E
você pode usar também a bil, né, sais
biliares, né, o oxybil, que são sais
biliares bovinos, ou o ácido tauro
deoxicólico, que é o túdica, que é um
úica mais avançado, tá?
Em relação aos cíos pancreáticos, os
cícios pancreáticos são bolsas cheias de
líquido que podem ser benignos ou
malignos. Na maioria das vezes eles vão
ser benignos. E o tratamento
convencional varia, né, se vai ser
benigno ou maligno. E pode ser
observação, pode ser drenagem
endoscópica, pode ser cirurgia,
dependendo do tipo, dependendo do
tamanho. Outras estratégias do ponto de
vista natural, além do que eu já falei,
você pode usar omôme 3, que vai ter ação
antiinflamatória,
reduzindo as prostagrandinas
inflamatórias. Você pode utilizar o
resveratrol, que vai ativar as cirtuínas
e reduzir a inflamação do pâncreas. Você
pode usar quercetina, que vai
estabilizar os mastóstos e reduzir as
citocinas pró-inflamatórias e dá suporte
também enzimático ao pâncreas com as já
citadas enzimas pancreáticas. E também
você pode usar, além da pancreatina,
pode usar lipase, prote, amilase,
bromelina ou bromelaína e papaína, que
são enzimas proteíticas que vão ter uma
ação antiinflamatória também, porque
elas correm no sangue e vão destruindo
imunocomplexos. além da ação local de
digestão e fazer uma modulação
metabólica nos potadores de císto de
pâncreas, uso de berberina, que vai
melhorar a sensibilidade, a insulina e a
função pancreática, uso do cromivanádio,
que vão dar um suporte metabolismo do
açúcar, o magnésio também que é
fundamental, é um cofator enzimático
essencial pra função pancreática. Vamos
falar um pouquinho de protocolo de detox
hepático. Você pode usar cimarina, a
famosa cimarina, né, que vai promover
patoproteção e regeneração, alcaxofra,
que vai estimular a produção biliar, o
dente de leão, que tem ação colerética e
diurética e modular o microbioma com
probióticos específicos, como é o caso
do lactobacos plantaron, do bife do
bactérium, que vão ajudar no metabolismo
dos ácidos biliares e usar também os
prebióticos, é o caso da inulina, é o
caso do fz, da fibra de acás que vão dar
suporte na microbiota intestinal, na
microbiota benéfica. Então, concluindo,
a abordagem integrada, ela deve sempre
considerar a investigação de causas
raízes, como disbiose intestinal,
sobrecarga, tóxica, deficiências
nutricionais e desequilíbrios hormonais
que podem perpetuar essas condições.
Então, é importante você passar com o
médico que entenda disso e fazer um
monitoramento regular com exames de
laboratório e ultrassonografia. Boa
sorte, um grande abraço. Compartilhe os
vídeos, faça bem. A vida de alguém pode
mudar também no canal do Tolendo,
desenvolva. Ah.